Narrator: TONIGHT, SILICON
VALLEY BILLIONAIRE CHRIS SACCA
RETURNS TO THE TANK.
IT'S NOT GOING THAT GREAT
FOR YOU.
IN THE TANK,
ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESSES.
BAM -- ALL YOUR NUTRITIONAL
INFORMATION IN A SNAP.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I'LL GIVE YOU
$2.5 MILLION.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
CHRIS IS A RAVING CAPITALIST
WHO DOESN'T GIVE A [BLEEP]
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR...
I DON'T REALLY LIKE YOU,
BUT I LIKE THE CONCEPT.
...OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
THERE ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT WAYS
THIS BUSINESS FAILS.
I NEED HELP.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHETHER
OR NOT THIS STUFF IS
EVEN GOING TO WORK.
CAN'T PLEASE EVERYONE.
YOUR PRESENTATION
WAS JUST TERRIBLE.
LET ME TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE TOTAL PICTURE HERE.
Sacca:
YOU'RE SERIOUS?
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
AND BILLIONAIRE INVESTOR
CHRIS SACCA
LEFT HIS HIGH-PROFILE POSITION
AT GOOGLE
AT THE HEIGHT OF HIS CAREER
TO START HIS OWN VENTURE-CAPITAL
FUND, WHICH IS NOW
ONE OF THE HIGHEST-PERFORMING
INVESTMENT FUNDS IN HISTORY,
WITH EARLY INVESTMENTS
IN TWITTER, INSTAGRAM, AND UBER.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS A PRODUCT DESIGNED TO PROMOTE
A HEALTHY LIFESTYLE.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME
IS MARTIN DELL'ARCIPRETE,
AND I'M FROM PHILADELPHIA, P.A.
MY COMPANY IS SmartPlate,
AND I'M SEEKING $1 MILLION
FOR A 15% STAKE IN MY COMPANY.
WHOA.
EVERY DAY,
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WORK HARD
TO MAINTAIN
A HEALTHIER LIFESTYLE.
FROM HEALTH-CONSCIOUS CONSUMERS
TO ELITE ATHLETES,
SUCCESS COMES DOWN
TO EATING SMART.
THE PROBLEM IS EATING SMART
WITH CURRENT SOLUTIONS
REQUIRES TEDIOUS
MANUAL CALORIE-COUNTING,
WHICH IS TIME CONSUMING,
FRUSTRATING,
AND, WORST OF ALL, INACCURATE.
SmartPlate IS THE WORLD'S FIRST
INTELLIGENT PLATE
THAT INSTANTLY ANALYZES
YOUR ENTIRE MEAL
WITH UP TO 99% ACCURACY.
IT USES FOOD-RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY AND LOAD SENSORS
TO IDENTIFY AND WEIGH EVERYTHING
SITTING ON ITS SURFACE.
FROM SINGLE FOODS
TO PREPARED MEALS,
LIKE PIZZA,
VEGETABLE-FRIED RICE,
AND EVEN A GARDEN SALAD.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IS PLACE YOUR FOOD ON THE PLATE
THE WAY YOU NORMALLY WOULD,
AND BAM --
GET ALL YOUR NUTRITIONAL
INFORMATION IN A SNAP.
WOW.
INCLUDING CALORIES, CARBS,
AND PROTEINS.
OUR MISSION IS TO GET SmartPlate
INTO THE HANDS
OF EVERY AMERICAN WHO WANTS
TO IMPROVE THEIR HEALTH.
SO, SHARKS, WHO'S READY TO TAKE
A BITE OUT OF SmartPlate?
DO YOU HAVE PLATES
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT?
YES, YES, I DO.
I'M GONNA HAVE TO SEE IT.
I'M GONNA HAND THOSE OUT
RIGHT NOW.
SO, WE HAVE A PROTOTYPE
OF OUR MERCHANDISING,
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE
A PROTOTYPE
OF THE SmartPlate.
A PROTOTYPE.
PRO-- UH-OH.
OH.
LET'S GET INTO
THE TECHNOLOGY.
YES. SO, THE WAY THAT IT WORKS
IS IT TAKES A PICTURE,
AND THEN IT ANALYZES
THE PICTURE,
AND IT'S ABLE
TO IDENTIFY THE FOOD.
COMBINES THAT
WITH THE WEIGHT INFORMATION.
ONCE WE HAVE BOTH OF THOSE,
THEN WE ARE ABLE TO TELL YOU
THE MICRO- AND MACRONUTRIENTS.
HOW DOES IT DIFFERENTIATE
FRIED RICE
WITH A CERTAIN TYPE OF OIL
AND ANOTHER TYPE OF OIL,
YOU KNOW?
SO, OILS AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE,
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO PICK UP,
BUT WE DO HAVE A SOLUTION
FOR THAT.
SO, WE GIVE CONSUMERS
THREE OPTIONS.
THEY CAN EITHER "SNAP IT,"
"SCAN IT," OR "SAY IT."
SO, WE HAVE OVER 350,000
CPG BARCODES.
IF SOMEBODY'S OUT
AT A RESTAURANT,
WE HAVE A DATABASE
OF RESTAURANT MEALS, AS WELL.
OVER 100,000
RESTAURANT MEALS.
SO, I'M FROM NEW YORK CITY.
AND HERE'S
WHAT WE BELIEVE --
ON THE EIGHTH DAY,
GOD MADE STREET MEAT.
THERE'S NO BARCODE
ON THE DIRTY, LITTLE HOT DOGS
THAT I EAT OUT THERE.
HOW -- HOW IS THAT
GONNA HELP ME?
IF YOU TAKE A PICTURE
OF THE HOT DOG,
WE'LL BE ABLE TO ANALYZE AND
IDENTIFY THAT IT'S A HOT DOG.
THEN, IF IT WAS -- IT WAS ON,
YOU KNOW, THE SmartPlate,
WE'D BE ABLE
TO IDENTIFY THE WEIGHT.
IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE
THE SmartPlate,
JUST WITH YOUR SMARTPHONE
AND THE "SNAP IT" FEATURE,
YOU'D BE ABLE
TO TAKE A PICTURE.
WE'D SAY
THAT IT'S A HOT DOG.
MARTIN, CAN YOU DEMONSTRATE
HOW THAT APP ACTUALLY WORKS
SO WE GET
A BETTER FEEL FOR IT?
I'D LOVE TO DO THAT.
WHAT'S FIRING RIGHT NOW
IS THE FOOD-RECOGNITION
PORTION.
WE DON'T HAVE
THE WEIGHT SENSORS
IN THESE
AESTHETIC PROTOTYPES YET,
BUT I CAN DEMONSTRATE THE
FUNCTIONALITY, IF THAT'S OKAY.
WE'RE GONNA HIT "SNAP IT."
THEN WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT
OUR PIECE OF PIZZA HERE.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A PICTURE.
[ CELLPHONE CAMERA CLICKS ]
AND, THEN WITHIN SECONDS,
IT'LL BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY IT.
AND THERE YOU SEE IT.
I SEE
THREE CAMERAS THERE.
YES.
SO, TALK ABOUT THOSE.
ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH, BECAUSE WHAT WERE YOU --
WHAT WERE USING YOUR PHONE FOR
IF THE CAMERAS ARE ALL
IN THIS -- IN THE PLATE.
I WAS -- SO, WHAT I WAS
USING MY PHONE FOR
WAS TO SIMULATE THE CAMERAS.
WE DON'T HAVE --
OH, YOU WERE SIMULATING
THESE CAMERAS IN HERE.
THAT'S CORRECT.
OKAY, YEAH, I UNDERSTAND.
BUT THOSE CAMERAS
CAN SEE THAT.
I MEAN, THE ASPECT --
IT'S ONE THING
TO GET AN OVERHEAD VIEW.
WE HAVE AN INDUSTRIAL-DESIGN
FIRM OUT OF PHILLY.
WE'VE GONE OVER
ALL THE SPECS.
WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO IS
IT'S GONNA BE LIFTED.
IT'S GONNA BE RAISED,
SO IT'S ABOVE THE FOOD, OKAY?
THE CAMERA'S
ABOVE THE FOOD?
IT'S GONNA BE ABLE TO GIVE US
A 180 VIEW.
GETTING TO MARKET, OKAY,
YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF STUFF
THAT YOU HAVE TO MAKE WORK.
PARTICULARLY
THE CAMERA TECHNOLOGY.
YES.
I USE THESE APPS.
IT WORKS.
YOU'RE NOT USING THE APP
PROPERLY.
THAT'S WHY I HAVE
AN ADONIS BODY.
SO,
AT THE END OF THE DAY,
I'M THINKING IF YOU SOLD
THE PLATE WITHOUT THE CAMERAS
AND I USED
JUST MY OWN PHONE,
COULDN'T I GET
A LOW-COST VERSION
AND GET TO MARKET
A LOT FASTER
THAN ALL THIS FUTURE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT?
LET ME JUST PAINT A LITTLE BIT
OF A BETTER PICTURE
AS TO WHERE WE STAND
CURRENTLY.
'CAUSE I SMELL PRE-REVENUE
ALL OVER THIS.
LET ME TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT SALES.
PRE-REVENUE?
IT'S PRE-PRODUCT.
LET ME TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE TOTAL PICTURE HERE.
CAN I BUY
A SmartPlate NOW?
WE'RE TAKING PRE-ORDERS.
WE'RE NOT PLANNING
TO DELIVER SmartPlate
UNTIL THE SUMMER OF 2016.
HOW MUCH IS THE PLATE
GONNA COST AT RETAIL?
YEAH, SO, IT'S GONNA RETAIL
FOR $199.
OH.
FOR US, THAT'S A 469% --
MARTIN, HONEY, SWEETIE, POOPSY,
THAT'S CRAZY.
HOW MUCH MONEY DO YOU HAVE INTO
THIS BUSINESS RIGHT NOW?
WE RAISED $225,000
FROM INSTITUTIONAL ACCREDITED
INVESTORS.
WE HAVE $80,000
FROM FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
AND WE'VE SOFT-CIRCLED $550,000
OF THIS ROUND.
SOFT-CIRCLED FROM?
SOFT-CIRCLE?
TECHNOLOGY PARTNERS.
IS THAT THE SOFT LIKE
SOFT-SERVE?
[ LAUGHS ]
NO, IT ISN'T.
YOU'RE TRYING TO CONVEY
THE MESSAGE
THAT OTHER PEOPLE
ARE INTERESTED.
I'M NOT ASKING THAT,
I JUST WANT --
THAT'S CORRECT, MARK. YES.
I GOT IT.
BUT I JUST --
I'M UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH THE WAY THAT
YOU'RE MAKING THIS PITCH.
WELL, TOO BAD, THEN.
YOU IN, YOU OUT?
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO,
DAYMOND?
IT'S A LITTLE...
AND SO, I'M OUT.
MARTIN, WHEN I LOOK AT
HOW PEOPLE EAT,
INCLUDING MYSELF
AND MY FAMILY,
I THINK THAT PEOPLE DON'T
EAT ALL THEIR FOOD
AT HOME
NEAR THE SmartPlate.
THEY HAVE LUNCH AT SCHOOL.
THEY HAVE LUNCH ON THE RUN.
THEY EAT AT A RESTAURANT
AT NIGHT.
YOU'RE GONNA SPEND
A LOT TIME AND MONEY
TRYING TO SELL
THESE PLATES TO PEOPLE,
AND I DON'T REALLY THINK
THEY HAVE ANY MERIT AT ALL.
I'M OUT.
HERE'S WHERE
I'M KIND OF GOING IN CIRCLES.
I DON'T SEE ANY TECHNOLOGY
THAT YOU GUYS INTRODUCED.
THIS IS
A TECHNOLOGICAL PRODUCT.
Dell'Arciprete:
MM-HMM. THAT'S CORRECT.
YOU'VE SOLD IT AS SUCH,
RIGHT?
YES.
IT IS.
YOU'RE TRYING
TO SELL THE VALUE,
AND WHAT I'M HEARING
IS THE VALUE PROPOSITION,
THE CORE COMPETENCY,
YOU'RE HIRING FROM
THIRD-PARTY DESIGN COMPANIES,
AND YOU'RE HOPING
THEY CAN MAKE IT WORK.
THEY'RE EXPERIENCED
IN THE SPACE.
WHAT IF IT DOESN'T WORK?
YOU'RE BETTING
YOUR ENTIRE COMPANY
ON SOME
EXTERNAL DESIGN COMPANY.
YOU GUYS CAN'T CONTROL
YOUR OWN DESTINY.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHETHER
OR NOT THIS STUFF IS
EVEN GOING TO WORK.
THAT IS A HUGE PROBLEM
FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
I GOT TO TELL YOU,
AS A TECHNOLOGIST,
I THINK
THE PLATE IS A CRUTCH.
IT'S AN INTERIM STEP
THAT WILL BE OBSOLETE
SOON ENOUGH.
IF YOUR PHOTO-RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY
WERE AS GOOD
AS IT SHOULD BE,
THEN IT CAN INFER
VOLUME AND MASS
FROM THE PICTURE
IT TAKES.
I DON'T NEED TO WEIGH
THE PIZZA.
I DON'T NEED TO TAKE AN
ANCILLARY PHOTO FROM THE SIDE.
SO, YOU'RE TRYING
TO SELL PEOPLE
A VERY EXPENSIVE,
VERY FRAGILE, HARD THING
THAT DOESN'T FIT
IN THEIR POCKET,
THAT CAN'T GO
WITH THEM ANYWHERE,
AND YOU'RE CHARGING
A LOT OF MONEY FOR IT.
THERE'S SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS
THIS BUSINESS FAILS
RIGHT OUT OF THE GATE,
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING,
BARBARA?
CAN I JUST MAKE ONE -- CAN I
MAKE A QUICK POINT, BARBARA?
CERTAINLY, GO AHEAD.
OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
BARBARA, I KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE A LOT OF INVESTMENTS
IN THE FOOD SPACE.
YES, I DO.
A LOT OF YOUR PORTFOLIO
IS IN THIS SPACE.
THERE'S CONSUMERS
THAT ARE OUT THERE,
AND THEY'RE DOING ALL THIS
MANUALLY.
YES.
WE AUTOMATE THAT --
WE AUTOMATE THAT PROCESS.
I FEEL SO BADLY,
'CAUSE YOU'RE SO HEARTFELT.
YET, YOUR PRESENTATION
REALLY WAS JUST TERRIBLE.
I'M SORRY TO SAY.
JUST TERRIBLE.
AND CONFUSING.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
Cuban:
GOOD LUCK, MARTIN.
GOOD LUCK.
THANKS A LOT, GUYS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I APPRECIATE IT.
IT WAS TOUGH.
YOU KNOW, THEY FIRED
A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
YOU KNOW, I TRIED TO KEEP
MY PASSION POINTS THERE.
I TRIED TO WALK THEM
THROUGH THE BUSINESS.
YOU KNOW, BUT IT WAS --
IT WAS A TOUGH DAY.
BUT, HONESTLY, YOU KNOW,
WE STILL BELIEVE IN SmartPlate
AND THE IMPACT THAT IT CAN HAVE
FOR CONSUMERS.
ALL I WANT RIGHT NOW
IS SOME STREET MEAT
WITH SOME
SOFT-SERVE ICE CREAM.
I'M KATIE SANCHEZ.
AND I'M MELISSA ELMS.
AND OUR COMPANY IS BASED
IN MINNEAPOLIS, MINNESOTA.
I'M ALWAYS KNOWN
MY WAY AROUND A KITCHEN.
I'M A TRAINED PASTRY CHEF.
SO TRYING NEW RECIPES,
IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I'VE ALWAYS DONE.
WOW.
PERFECT.
I MET KATIE
AT A FOOD TRADE SHOW,
AND WE DECIDED TO STICK TOGETHER
AND BECOME BUSINESS PARTNERS.
pH OF 3.7.
OUR PRODUCT
IS A SWEETENER
THAT TASTES AND BAKES
LIKE TRADITIONAL HONEY,
BUT WHAT MAKES IT
REALLY GREAT
IS IT STEMS
FROM A DIFFERENT SOURCE.
OUR GOAL IS
TO HELP SAVE THE BEES.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE POPULATION
OF THESE TINY WORKERS
IS IN DECLINE.
OUR PRODUCT HELPS
TO GIVE THE BEES A BREAK,
ALLOWS THEM TO REGAIN IN HEALTH
AND IN NUMBERS.
WE'LL GET THAT ORDER
RIGHT OUT TO YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'VE PUT EVERYTHING
INTO THIS BUSINESS --
SPIRITUALLY, EMOTIONALLY,
AND FINANCIALLY.
THIS BUSINESS
IS SO IMPORTANT
'CAUSE IT'S GOING TO MAKE A
CHANGE IN THE SWEETENER MARKET,
AND IT OFFERS A SOLUTION
TO MULTIPLE PROBLEMS,
NOT JUST TODAY,
BUT FOR TOMORROW, AS WELL.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S KATIE SANCHEZ,
AND I'M FROM MINNEAPOLIS,
MINNESOTA.
AND I'M MELISSA ELMS,
FROM NOLANVILLE, TEXAS.
AND WE ARE THE OWNERS
AND OPERATORS
OF BEE FREE HONEE.
WE ARE HERE SEEKING $100,000
FOR 10% EQUITY IN OUR COMPANY.
SHARKS, WE'VE ALL HEARD
THE EXPRESSION "BUSY AS A BEE."
THEY'RE BUSY FOR A REASON.
IT TAKES OVER 60,000 BEES
TO GATHER ENOUGH NECTAR
FOR ONE POUND OF HONEY.
WOW.
WELL,
WE AT BEE FREE HONEE SAY,
LET'S GIVE THOSE BEES
A REST.
THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE OUR LINE
OF 100%-PLANT-BASED,
SUSTAINABLE HONEY.
NO HIVES REQUIRED.
HOW DO WE DO IT?
BEE FREE IS THE ONLY ALTERNATIVE
HONEY ON THE MARKET...
...MADE FROM APPLES.
WE MAKE ALL OF OUR PRODUCTS
IN OUR KITCHEN
USING ONLY APPLES
GROWN IN THE U.S.A.
BEE FREE HONEE
CAN BE USED ON BREADS,
AS A TOPPING ON GRANOLAS
OR OATMEALS.
YOU CAN USE BEE FREE HONEE
AS THE PERFECT SUBSTITUTE.
SHARKS, WE INVITE YOU
TO ENJOY BEE FREE HONEE
SO YOU CAN SEE
WHAT ALL THE "BUZZ" IS ABOUT.
WE HAVE SOME SAMPLES.
YOU CAN GRAB EITHER ONE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
SO, WHAT YOU HAVE
IN FRONT OF YOU,
IT'S 80% U.S.-GROWN
ORGANIC APPLE.
LEMON JUICE IS
THE ONLY PRESERVATIVE.
AND THEN THERE'S A TITCH
OF VEGAN-QUALITY
NON-GMO CANE SUGAR.
ONLY ENOUGH TO GIVE IT
THE VISCOSITY
OF TRADITIONAL HONEY.
AND THOSE ARE
THE THREE MAIN INGREDIENTS.
IT TASTES GOOD, GUYS.
OH, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
IT TASTES LIKE HONEY.
THIS STUFF IS
VERY, VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU.
O'Leary: SO, KATIE, CAN I JUST
ASK YOU A BASIC QUESTION
BEFORE WE GET INTO
AND DIVE DEEP INTO THIS?
SURE.
WHY DOES
THE WORLD NEED THIS?
Elms: NOT ONLY DOES IT HELP
WITH THE BEE POPULATION,
BUT OUR VEGAN COMMUNITY
IS A BIG SUPPORTER OF OURS.
VEGANS DO NOT EAT HONEY?
VEGANS DO NOT EAT HONEY.
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
CONTESTED INGREDIENTS
IN THE VEGAN COMMUNITY
BY FAR.
WHY?
IT COMES FROM AN ANIMAL,
AN INSECT.
John:
YOU KNOW, SOMEBODY CAME ON HERE
LAST SEASON -- BEE THINKING.
I TOOK
ONE OF THE HIVES HOME,
AND I'VE BECOME NOW ABSOLUTELY,
TOTALLY OBSESSED WITH BEES.
I HAVE A MILLION BEES
ON MY PROPERTY.
AND I JUST KNOW SO MUCH
ABOUT THIS STUFF NOW.
IF YOU TAKE OUT MORE
THAN ABOUT 20% OF THE HONEY,
IT COULD
COLLAPSE THE HIVE.
WHERE DOES THIS COMPARE PRICING
TO HONEY?
Elms: IT'S AT THE SAME PRICE
OR LOWER,
BUT IT COST US TO PRODUCE
$1.60 A UNIT.
AND WE SELL IT FOR $5.99
A BOTTLE AT RETAIL.
AND IS THAT
WHAT I WOULD PAY
FOR ANOTHER JAR OF HONEY,
OR WHAT EXACTLY?
YOU'D PROBABLY PAY
AROUND $10.99 AND UP.
WOW.
AND WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
SO, WE'VE BEEN ON THE NATIONAL
MARKET NOW FOR TWO YEARS.
WE ARE IN 9 OF THE 11 REGIONS
OF WHOLE FOODS.
OUR SALES ARE THIS YEAR TO DATE
$104,000 IN REVENUE STREAM.
LAST YEAR, $78,000,
OUR FIRST YEAR
OUT OF THE GATE.
WHY DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THIS
COMPANY IS WORTH $1 MILLION?
WELL, WE'VE JUST
FINISHED TESTING
WITH COSTCO IN THE BAY AREA,
AS WELL,
AND WE ARE GOING -- WE'RE
WORKING ON PACKAGING RIGHT NOW
FOR A ROLL-OUT WITH THEM
THIS LATE FALL.
IF YOU WERE TO GET YOUR
INVESTMENT TODAY OF $100,000,
IS THAT ENOUGH MONEY
TO CASH FLOW THOSE ORDERS?
YES.
YES. YOU FEEL SO.
YOU'VE DONE THE NUMBERS?
Sanchez: WE PUT EVERYTHING
BACK INTO THE COMPANY.
YEAH, THE $100,000
IS GONNA BE FOR US
TO BUILD
OUR OWN KITCHEN.
YOU HAVE NEED
FOR A LARGER KITCHEN
TO GET THOSE OTHER ORDERS?
YES, MA'AM.
WE HAVE
CAP ON OUR SALES
BECAUSE WE HAVE A CAP
ON PRODUCTION HOURS.
SO, I'VE GOT
A COUPLE OF RESTAURANTS.
IF I TAKE THIS TO MY CHEF
AND SAY,
"CHEF, DO YOU WANT TO USE THIS
IN YOUR PASTRIES?"
ARE YOU GOING TO BE ABLE
TO BEAT THAT
TO WHERE YOU ARE A CHEAPER,
JUST-AS-DELICIOUS COMMODITY?
IF YOUR CHEF IS USING
ORGANIC, LOCAL HONEY,
THEN OUR PRODUCT'S GONNA BE
OBVIOUSLY LOWER-PRICED.
WHAT IF THEY'RE USING, LIKE,
JUST HONEY OFF THE TRUCK?
OURS IS GONNA BE
RELATIVELY THE SAME PRICE.
WELL,
THAT'S NO GOOD, CHRIS.
THAT'S NO GOOD.
IF THEY BUY IN BULK.
YEAH,
BUT THAT'S IRRELEVANT.
IT IS RELEVANT!
IF I WALK INTO A GROCERY STORE
WITH MY KIDS,
AND IT SAYS "BUY THIS,
SAVE THE LIVES OF 1,000 BEES,"
THIS IS
A $100 MILLION BRAND.
UGH.
WHY NOT SAY YOU'RE GONNA SAVE
THE UNBORN BABY WHALES
WHILE YOU'RE AT IT?
YOU KNOW, LADIES,
I, UH, I DON'T GET --
UH,
I DON'T GET THE WHOLE THING.
HOW MANY YEARS HAVE YOU
BEEN DOING THIS?
I STARTED THE -- I WAS TRYING
TO MAKE APPLE JELLY,
AND I DIDN'T READ
THE DIRECTIONS,
AND I WOUND UP
MAKING THIS BY ACCIDENT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
RIGHT ON.
AND THAT HAPPENED IN 1999.
AND THEN,
WHEN I STARTED HEARING ABOUT --
1999 -- SO 15 YEARS AGO.
BUT I DIDN'T START WORKING ON
THIS AS A PRODUCT IN 1999.
THAT'S WHEN
THE ACCIDENT HAPPENED.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU'VE MADE HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS
IN 15 YEARS.
I'M REALLY EXCITED
FOR YOU.
I'M GOING TO ALLOW BARBARA
TO GIVE YOU HER GOOD MONEY,
SO I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I LIKE THE FACT
THAT YOUR PRODUCT
IS WRAPPED AROUND A CAUSE --
SAVE THE BEES.
BUT I DON'T THINK
YOU DELIVER THE CAUSE
WITH YOUR PACKAGING.
Cuban: NO, THEY DON'T AT ALL.
YOU DON'T COME CLOSE.
RIGHT.
'CAUSE "BEE FREE"
JUST SAYS
IT'S, YOU KNOW, HONEY
THAT'S NOT MADE FORM BEES.
John: IF YOU'RE GONNA PUT
SOME KIND OF LABELING ON IT
THAT WILL SAY
HOW MANY BEES IT WILL SAVE,
PLUS CONTRIBUTE MONEY TOWARD
SOME FORM OF BEE EDUCATION --
IT COULD BE
25 CENTS A BOTTLE --
I WOULD GIVE YOU $100,000
FOR 25%,
AND WE CAN HAVE A DEAL
RIGHT NOW.
WHAT?
YEAH, DON'T DO THAT YET.
DON'T DO THAT YET.
YEAH.
LOOK, YOU'VE GOT
ALL THESE SHARKS
LYING IN WAIT RIGHT NOW.
[ BLOWS ]
I'M ABOUT TO WARM THIS UP.
COME ON.
LOOK, ALL RIGHT.
I'VE BEEN LYING IN WAIT
OVER HERE.
I HAVE A COUPLE SECRETS.
ONE -- I WAS VEGAN
FOR A LONG TIME.
AWESOME.
SO, I AM AN INVESTOR
IN THE FASTEST-GROWING FAST,
CASUAL RESTAURANT IN AMERICA,
WHICH IS VEGGIE GRILL --
A PLANT-BASED RESTAURANT
THAT IS KICKING ASS AND
TAKING NAMES ALL OVER AMERICA.
WHY? BECAUSE IT'S CHEAP
AND INCREDIBLY DELICIOUS,
AND THE INGREDIENTS
THEY WANT TO SOURCE
ARE THOSE THAT COMPLY
WITH A PLANT-BASED STAFF,
BUT ARE CHEAP ENOUGH THAT
THERE'S STILL MARGIN FOR THEM.
NOW, THE MILLION BUCKS,
I THINK,
IS A LITTLE BIT OF A STRETCH FOR
WHERE YOU ARE IN TERMS OF SALES.
THAT SAID,
I DO WORRY THAT 100 GRAND
ISN'T ENOUGH MONEY
FOR YOU.
I ACTUALLY THINK YOU NEED
MORE THAN $100,000.
Narrator: ONE SHARK IS OUT.
MELISSA AND KATIE HAVE ONE OFFER
ON THE TABLE FROM DAYMOND --
$100,000 FOR 25% OF THEIR HONEY
ALTERNATIVE, BEE FREE HONEE,
BUT OTHER SHARKS ARE CIRCLING.
I ACTUALLY THINK YOU NEED MORE
THAN $100,000.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $200,000
FOR 30% OF YOUR COMPANY.
I'LL MATCH THAT --
I'LL GIVE YOU $100,000 FOR 15%
OR $200,000 FOR 30%.
O'Leary:
SO, YOU HAVE TWO OFFERS.
CHRIS IS
A RAVING CAPITALIST,
DOESN'T GIVE A [BLEEP]
ABOUT THE BEES.
DAYMOND OVER HERE IS
VERY WORRIED ABOUT THE BEES.
AND MARK'S MADE THIS WHOLE THING
UP, AND WHILE HE'S AT IT,
HE COULD SAVE GIRAFFES WITH
THIS PRODUCT -- WHO KNOWS?
I'M HAPPY TO LET SOMEBODY IN
FOR A PART OF THE DEAL
IF THEY WANT TO GO WAVE THE FLAG
ABOUT THE BEE BUSINESS,
BUT WHAT MAKES THIS BIG IS THAT
YOU ARE BETTER AND CHEAPER.
THIS OFFER'S EVEN BETTER.
IT'S EVEN SWEETER.
I'LL GIVE YOU $100,000
FOR 10% OF THE BUSINESS.
BUT I WILL THEN DO
20% OF THE ONLINE SALES,
AND I'LL RUN THAT
FOR YOU.
IT TAKES THAT PART
OF THE BUSINESS OFF THE TABLE,
AND THEN YOU KEEP
MORE EQUITY.
BARBARA, ARE YOU IN OR OUT?
YOU KNOW WHAT,
I'LL TAKE THE WHOLE DEAL
OR HALF THE DEAL,
BUT I'M THE PARTNER
YOU WANT.
GUYS, LOOK,
I LIKE TO ALWAYS PUT MYSELF
IN THE SHOES
OF THE ENTREPRENEUR.
AS SOON AS I FINISH...
WAIT. BARBARA. I'M GONNA CIRCLE
BACK TO YOU, BARBARA.
I WANT TO HEAR
WHAT BARBARA SAID.
I'M GONNA
COME BACK TO YOU.
I'M NOT GONNA
LEAVE YOU HANGING.
OKAY, GUYS,
YOU NEED CHRIS FOR COMMERCIAL.
IT REALLY BENEFITS YOU
TO HAVE IT IN HIS RESTAURANT --
THAT ACCELERATES IT,
AND IT GIVES YOU
A COOLNESS FACTOR, AS WELL.
BARBARA YOU NEED
FOR THE HAND-HOLDING, RIGHT?
YOU DON'T NEED ME
FOR THE HAND-HOLDING.
YOU NEED ME
FOR BUILDING YOUR BRAND,
LIKE I BUILT
PORK BARREL BBQ SAUCE...
MM-HMM.
DAISY CAKES,
TOM AND CHEE, COUSINS,
...ALL DOING
AN EXCESS OF $10 MILLION,
AND THEY STARTED
WITH LESS THAN $200,000.
YOU NEED ME
FOR MY FOOD EXPERTISE
AND MY MARKETING
EXPERTISE.
ARE YOU WILLING
TO GO IN TOGETHER?
THAT'S WHY I'VE BEEN ASKING HER
TO CLEAR --
TURNS OUT, BY THE WAY,
I KNOW A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT SOCIAL MEDIA, TOO.
I WOULD RATHER HAVE
MARK AS MY PARTNER,
BECAUSE HE'S A LOT
BETTER-LOOKING
THAN THIS COWBOY
ON THE LEFT.
[ Laughing ]
OH, MY GOODNESS!
BARBARA, I THINK
WE'D BENEFIT WITH CHRIS IN.
RIGHT?
WELL, OKAY.
SO, THREE SHARKS...
YEAH, THREE FOR THREE.
...AND YOU GET
TO BEE LOVING.
Sacca: WAIT,
I STILL HAVEN'T HEARD --
BARBARA SAID, "HALF THE DEAL,"
"ALL THE DEAL" --
WHAT'S THE DEAL?
NO, NO.
I WAS GOING TO TAKE
HALF OF YOUR DEAL
IF YOU WANTED ME TO.
WAIT -- HALF OF MY DEAL,
BUT WITHOUT ME?
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'D PREFER IT.
DUDE,
I COPYWRITED THAT DEAL.
SO, CHRIS OFFERED
$200,000 FOR 30%.
WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST
IS $210,000 FOR 30% --
$70,000 FROM EACH OF US,
10% FOR EACH OF US.
YOU'LL GET
OUR EXPERTISE.
I LIKE THAT A LOT.
I COULD TAKE OVER
THE WEBSITE.
I'VE GOT
ALL THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
I'LL TAKE OVER
THE GROCERY END.
WAIT. AM I ALLOWED BACK
INTO MY OWN DEAL?
NO.
I'M ASKING YOU RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S A THREE-WAY.
THANKS FOR LETTING ME BACK
INTO MY OWN DEAL.
[ SANCHEZ LAUGHS ]
JUST SO WE'RE CLEAR --
$210,000...
FOR 30%.
...FOR 30% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
SO $70,000 FROM EACH,
BASICALLY, 10 POINTS EACH?
RIGHT. CORRECT.
IMAGINE YOUR CONFERENCE CALL
WITH THESE GUYS.
[ ELMS AND SANCHEZ LAUGH ]
BUT WHAT HAPPENS, THEN,
WHEN YOU NEED A REAL PARTNER?
SHARKS,
YOU'VE GOT A DEAL.
HEY, YEAH!
ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS GONNA BE A BIG HUG.
NO-BRAINER!
[ LAUGHS ]
SWEET!
THANK YOU.
OH, MY GOSH!
CONGRATULATIONS.
WOW. THANK YOU.
THAT STUFF IS DELICIOUS.
OH, MY GOSH.
Corcoran: MY PLEASURE.
OH, WE WANTED TO WORK
WITH YOU ALL SO MUCH.
TERRIFIC JOB.
THAT STUFF IS SO DELICIOUS.
Sanchez:
OH, THANK YOU SO MUCH!
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH.
THANK YOU!
APPRECIATE IT.
[ LAUGHS ]
[ Laughing ]
OH, MY GOD!
Sanchez: WE WENT
DEEP-SEA FISHING,
AND WE CAUGHT THREE SHARKS!
THREE SHARKS!
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
Narrator: IN SEASON 5,
MARK CUBAN INVESTED
IN AN APP-CONTROLLED
SMART-LIGHT BULB CALLED ILUMI.
YOU'VE GOT A DEAL.
I KNEW IT!
LET'S GO TO WORK!
Narrator: LET'S SEE
HOW ILUMI IS DOING NOW.
♪♪
TODAY, WE'RE EXHIBITING ILUMI
SMARTBULBS AT CES IN LOS VEGAS.
THIS TRADE SHOW
IS THE PLACE TO SEE
THE LATEST IN ELECTRONICS
AND CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY.
WE'RE HERE TO SHOWCASE OUR
SECOND-GENERATION SMARTBULBS.
AND TO LAUNCH
A BRAND-NEW APP.
SINCE WE STARTED
WORKING WITH MARK,
WE SECURED PLACEMENT
IN MAJOR RETAILERS,
LIKE BEST BUY, FRY'S,
BROOKSTONE,
AND EVEN HOME DEPOT
IN CANADA.
WE'VE GONE
FROM A PRE-REVENUE COMPANY
TO ACHIEVING $2 MILLION
IN SALES.
Cuban:
WHAT'S UP, GUYS?
HEY!
HEY, MARK.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
Cuban: CES IS NOT
YOUR TYPICAL TRADE SHOW.
EVERYBODY IS HERE --
MEDIA, CELEBRITIES.
IF IT'S EXHIBITED HERE,
THE WORLD KNOWS.
THIS ISN'T
A LIGHT BULB COMPANY --
THIS IS A BLUETOOTH MESH
NETWORKING COMPANY
THAT'LL BE ABLE TO CONTROL
ANY TYPE OF DEVICE
WITHOUT HAVING TO USE
THE INTERNET.
I KNOW WITH BEST BUY,
WE'VE REALLY AMPLIFIED THINGS.
THEY COULD REALLY
CHANGE THE GAME,
AND THAT'S WHAT I LOOK FOR
IN "SHARK TANK."
WHEN YOU CAN INVEST
IN A GAME-CHANGER,
THAT'S WHERE
THE REAL MONEY'S MADE.
NOW LET'S GO SELL
SOME LIGHT BULBS.
LET'S DO IT!
AMAZON'S EXCITED
TO WORK WITH YOU GUYS.
AWESOME.
Egan: SO FAR,
EVERYONE SEEMS TO LOVE
OUR ILUMI SMARTBULBS.
IT'S BEEN A REAL-BIG HIT.
"SHARK TANK" HAS DONE MORE
FOR OUR BUSINESS
THAN WE COULD EVER
IMAGINE.
WE BELIEVE THAT ILUMI
IS THE FUTURE
OF SMART-LIGHTING
TECHNOLOGY,
AND WE'RE SO GLAD THAT MARK
INVESTED IN OUR BRIGHT IDEA.
All: LIVE YOUR LIGHT!
[ CHEERING ]
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A BUSINESS DEDICATED
TO HELPING BABIES THRIVE.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS KRISTI ISON,
AND I AM THE PROUD FOUNDER
AND SOLE OWNER OF FLOAT BABY.
TODAY, I AM SEEKING $150,000
FOR 20% OF MY COMPANY.
SHARKS, WE ALL KNOW THAT
PEOPLE WHO EXERCISE WEEKLY
HAVE IMPROVED PHYSICAL
AND COGNITIVE STRENGTH.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE ROUTINE MASSAGES
CAN EXPERIENCE IMPROVED
BLOOD FLOW AND MUSCLE TONE.
FLOAT BABY
IS THE FIRST AND ONLY
FLOATATION AND MASSAGE FACILITY
IN THE U.S. FOR BABIES.
BABIES AS YOUNG AS TWO WEEKS USE
HYDROTHERAPY AND INFANT MASSAGE
TO BECOME HAPPIER AND --
BELIEVE IT OR NOT --
STRONGER, SMARTER BABIES.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ LAUGHTER CONTINUES ]
SORRY, SORRY.
[ LAUGHS ]
[ Laughing ] I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY.
[ LAUGHTER CONTINUES ]
OH, MY GOD.
Sacca:
YOU'RE SERIOUS?
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
AFTER FLOATING BABIES
OVER 1,000 TIMES,
I ASSURE YOU
THIS IS A PROVEN CONCEPT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, RATHER THAN SWIM
WITH THE SHARKS,
WHO WANTS TO FLOAT
WITH THE BABIES?
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHO'S PROVEN
THAT THIS WORKS?
YEAH, YOU MADE
AN AWFUL LOT OF CLAIMS.
I DID.
WHERE ARE THOSE
BACKED UP?
IT'S VALIDATED
BY SEVEN OTHER COUNTRIES.
THIS IS NOT A NEW --
NO, NO, NO, NO.
THAT'S NOT AN ANSWER.
OKAY.
THAT MEANS NOTHING.
CAN YOU POINT TO ANY RESEARCH
THAT SHOWS
THAT BABIES WHO FLOAT
OR ARE MASSAGED
HAVE BETTER
HEALTH OUTCOMES?
YOU EVEN SAID
COGNITIVE OUTCOMES, TOO.
YES.
INFANT MASSAGE IS DONE ACROSS
THE U.S. IN HOSPITAL N.I.C.U.s
FOR PREMATURE BABIES TO HELP
STIMULATE THE GROWTH HORMONE...
SURE.
...HELP THEM EAT BETTER,
GROW FASTER.
THE LARGEST STUDY
ON EARLY WATER PROGRAMS
WAS DONE BY GRIFFITH UNIVERSITY
OUT OF AUSTRALIA.
AND THEY LOOKED AT
7,000 CHILDREN UNDER AGE 5.
AND THEY FOUND THAT THE BABIES
WHO WERE IN THE WATER PROGRAM
HIT THEIR MILESTONE MARKERS
BY AS MUCH AS 50% AHEAD
OF THE NON-WATER GROUP.
John:
SO, KRISTI, I JUST WANT TO KNOW,
WHO WAS THE FIRST PERSON
TO SNAP A HEMORRHOID PILLOW
AROUND A BABY'S NECK
AND FLOAT THEM
DOWN THE RIVER?
[ LAUGHS ]
LIKE,
WHO STARTED THIS CONCEPT?
THIS WAS STARTED IN JAPAN
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO.
THERE ARE SEVERAL COMPANIES
THAT MAKE THIS FLOATATION RING.
I HAVE A PATENT PENDING
ON THE COVER.
IT'S SMALLER THAN ANY OF
THE EXISTING FLOATATION DEVICES
ON THE MARKET.
WE COULD START SEEING BABIES
AS EARLY AS 2 WEEKS.
SO,
EXPLAIN TO ME THE BUSINESS.
IS THE BUSINESS, YOU KNOW,
A LOCATION?
SO, WE HAVE A STORE FRONT.
EACH BABY HAS
THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL TUB.
I HAVE THREE CURRENTLY,
SO WE RUN THREE BABIES
PER CLASS.
THEY FLOAT FOR ABOUT
20 TO 25 MINUTES.
HOW MUCH IS 1 HOUR?
1 HOUR IS $65.
ALL RIGHT.
WHEW.
IF I WANTED TO START
MR. WONDERFUL'S FLOAT-A-TRON,
I COULD DO IT.
THERE'S NOTHING YOU HAVE --
NO ONE WOULD BRING THEIR BABY
TO YOU, KEVIN.
OH, ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
O'Leary: I MEAN,
THE WHOLE POINT IS,
YOU COULD HAVE COMPETITION
NEXT DOOR RIGHT AWAY.
THIS IS LIKE A NAIL SALON,
ISN'T IT?
IT IS NOT A NAIL SALON.
WHY NOT?
FOR ONE REASON,
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
I'M HERE.
I NEED DEEPER TUBS.
CURRENTLY, I AM HAVING
TO GRADUATE MY CLIENTS
PREMATURELY AT 6 MONTHS,
BECAUSE OF THE DEPTH
OF MY TUBS.
I'VE LOCATED
A MANUFACTURER IN CHINA
THAT MAKES SPECIFIC TUBS
FOR THIS.
THEY'RE BABY SPA TUBS.
WHAT WERE YOUR TOTAL SALES
OVER THE PAST 12 MONTHS?
$44,000 THE FIRST YEAR,
AND WE ARE ON TRACK
TO DO $60,000 THIS YEAR.
OKAY, SO YOU'RE NOT SELLING OUT
ALL YOUR TIME SLOTS RIGHT NOW.
I'M NOT.
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE
RIGHT HERE.
THAT'S MY SECOND CHALLENGE,
WHICH IS --
THAT'S
YOUR FIRST CHALLENGE.
THAT'S MY FIRST CHALLENGE.
BECAUSE
IF YOU SELL ENOUGH,
THEN YOU CREATE ALL THE DOLLARS
YOU NEED FOR YOUR TUB.
THAT'S TRUE.
YEAH, I KNOW IT IS.
UM...
John: SO MAYBE THAT'S
A DIFFERENT QUESTION.
IN THE WORLD OF DIGITAL
MARKETING,
I THINK THAT THINGS
SHOULD BE GOING VIRAL.
I MEAN, YOU CAN GO
TO THE "MOMMY AND ME" CLASS,
YOU CAN GO TO LITTLE MOMS
ON FACEBOOK.
YEAH, EXACTLY.
SO WHERE DO YOU STAND
ON THAT AREA?
THERE ARE IS SO MUCH MONEY
BEING SPENT IN THIS SPACE.
BUT I WANTED TO KNOW --
ARE YOU STRONG IN
MARKETING IN THAT AREA?
IS SOCIAL MEDIA
MY STRONG POINT?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
IT CAN BE.
THIS THING SHOULD GO VIRAL
AT THIS POINT, ALL RIGHT?
LOOK, KRISTI, I'M GONNA ASK YOU
A VERY SIMPLE QUESTION.
OKAY.
WHAT'S YOUR GRIND?
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
LOOK,
HERE'S WHAT I'M SAYING --
THE GRIND IS, YOU GOT
TO GET OUT THERE AND SELL.
YOU CAN CONTROL YOUR OWN DESTINY
BY GRINDING --
MEANING YOU'RE GOING TO
THE "MOMMY AND ME" CLASSES.
HERE'S A CARD, HERE'S A FLYER,
HERE'S WHATEVER.
YOU'RE GOING
TO WHEREVER MOMS ARE,
AND SAYING, "HERE'S A COUPON"
AND THEY CAN COME FOR FREE.
THAT'S A GRIND -- GOING OUT
THERE AND GETTING IN YOUR CAR
AND GRINDING AND GOING
AND SELLING.
MY BACKGROUND IS
IN MEDICAL-DEVICE SALES.
I'VE WORKED FOR STARTUP
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES
FOR 18 YEARS.
SO, THEN YOU KNOW
TO GO OUT THERE AND SELL.
SO I DO KNOW
HOW TO GO AND SELL,
AND IN BETWEEN THOSE CLASSES
WHERE I DON'T HAVE BABIES,
I AM MEETING WITH DOCTORS,
I AM MEETING WITH PEDIATRIC PTs.
THEN SOMETHING IS WRONG.
RIGHT?
SOMETHING MISSING.
IS THAT YIELDING BUSINESS?
ARE YOU SEEING THAT
PRODUCE RESULTS?
Ison: IT IS YIELDING BUSINESS
BUT THIS IS A BUSINESS
THAT IS BUILDING, AND --
IT DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE IT'S BUILDING.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I'M LOOKING AT
YOUR BUSINESS,
AND I CAN'T SEE
THE THING
THAT YOU ARE
UNIQUELY AMAZING AT.
I SEE THIS AS A BUSINESS
FOR YOU INDIVIDUALLY,
BUT I DON'T SEE IT
AS SOMETHING BIG,
AND SO, FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
John: YOU KNOW, IN BUSINESS
THERE ARE THE FUNDAMENTALS --
PURELY THE FUNDAMENTALS.
MONEY'S NOT GONNA
SOLVE ANYTHING.
MONEY JUST DRIVES YOU UP
TO YOUR PROBLEMS IN A BUGATTI.
THAT'S WHAT I ALWAYS TELL
EVERYBODY.
YOUR BIGGEST CHALLENGE
IS THE FACT THAT YOU DON'T KNOW
HOW TO GET THE MESSAGE OUT TO
EVERYBODY IN A VERY SAVVY WAY --
CREATE A TRIBE,
CREATE A FOLLOWING
TO COME TO YOU
AND UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING OF VALUE
FOR EVERYBODY.
I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU
THAT I ABSOLUTELY NEED HELP
WITH THAT.
WELL, IT'S GONNA BE SOMETHING
THAT YOU NEED TO DO YOURSELF.
SO...
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I THINK YOU ARE
A GREAT PRACTITIONER,
AND REALLY BELIEVE
IN YOUR PRODUCT.
BUT THERE IS ONE THING
THAT EVERY ENTREPRENEUR
THAT I'VE INVESTED IN
HAS IN COMMON,
IS TREMENDOUS ENERGY
AND TREMENDOUS HUSTLE.
SO, I THINK YOU NEED
A SALESMAN/HUSTLER AS
A BUSINESS PARTNER,
OR ACCEPT THE FACT THAT THIS IS
A LOVELY PERSONAL PRACTICE.
BUT I CERTAINLY DON'T THINK
IT'S INVESTABLE.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
O'Leary: KRISTI,
I HAVE A DIFFERENT PROBLEM.
I LAUGHED HEARTILY AT THE VIDEO
'CAUSE IT'S FUNNY,
BUT I BOUGHT INTO THE MERITS.
OKAY, I BELIEVE IT.
IF YOU'D COME IN HERE
AND SAID TO ME,
"LOOK, I'M GONNA USE
THE 'SHARK TANK' PLATFORM
TO LET PEOPLE KNOW
THAT THIS EXISTS,
AND THEN I'M GOING
TO SELL THEM THE DOUGHNUT.
AND MY DOUGHNUT'S BETTER
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN PROVEN,
AND I'VE REDESIGNED
THE CHOKE COLLAR --
OR WHATEVER YOU CALL IT.
THEY'RE GONNA WANT TO ORDER ONE
FOR $69.95."
HE'S RIGHT.
WHO CARES ABOUT
A BABY SPA?
IT'S IRRELEVANT.
YOU CANT LEVERAGE THAT.
IT'S GREAT FOR YOU.
OKAY.
BUT HOW DO I, AS AN INVESTOR,
AFTER GIVING YOU $150,000,
MAKE $1 MILLION,
MAKE $2 MILLION,
MAKE $5 MILLION?
WELL, I APPRECIATE
THAT FEEDBACK.
WE DID CONSIDER
SELLING THE RINGS.
WE THOUGHT
THAT IT WOULD BE...
AND THE TUBS.
WELL, I'M NOT GONNA SELL THEM
TO PEOPLE FOR THEIR HOME USE.
WHY NOT?
DON'T YOU SEE
WHAT YOU MISSED?
DON'T YOU DESERVE
TO BE PUNISHED?
[ Chuckling ] NO!
OF COURSE YOU DO.
I NEED HELP.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
WELL, LOOK...
I'VE PROVEN THE CONCEPT,
PEOPLE ARE COMING...
I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'RE GONNA TAKE IN
THE ADVICE
YOU'VE BEEN GIVEN.
THIS IS NOT
THE "ADVICE TANK."
IT'S AN INVESTORS
OPPORTUNITY.
I DON'T SEE ANY CHANCE
OF MAKING MONEY WITH YOU.
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK.
WITH IT BEING
A BRAND-NEW CONCEPT IN THE U.S.,
IT'S VERY EASY
TO SIT BACK AND SAY,
"YOU SHOULD'VE DONE THIS,
YOU SHOULD'VE DONE THAT."
I'M GONNA KEEP DOING
WHAT I'M DOING.
THE PARENTS LOVE
AND I THINK THIS IS GONNA BE
THE NEXT BIG THING.
I JUST WANT TO SEE THAT VIDEO
ONE MORE TIME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, THAT IS FUNNY.
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A HIGH-TECH SOLUTION
TO ACHIEVE THE PERFECT FIT.
♪♪
HI.
I'M MILES PENN.
I'M HERE FROM SAN FRANCISCO,
AND I'M SEEKING $2.5 MILLION
IN EXCHANGE FOR A 10% EQUITY
STAKE IN MY COMPANY, MTailor.
AS A GUY, I HATE GOING TO
THE MALL AND TRYING ON CLOTHES.
BUT ONLINE SHOPPING
IS EVEN WORSE,
BECAUSE I'LL ORDER FIVE SHIRTS
JUST TO GET ONE THAT FITS OKAY.
CUSTOM CLOTHING PROVIDES
THE PERFECT FIT,
BUT IT'S REALLY EXPENSIVE,
AND IT'S EVEN MORE OF A HASSLE
THAN REGULAR SHOPPING.
UNTIL NOW.
MTailor SELLS
MEN'S CUSTOM SHIRTS
BY MEASURING YOU
WITH YOUR PHONE'S CAMERA.
AND WE'RE 20% MORE ACCURATE
THAN A PROFESSIONAL TAILOR.
IN THE MTailor APP,
THERE ARE OVER 10,000
UNIQUE SHIRT COMBINATIONS,
BUT IT'S INCREDIBLY SIMPLE
TO ORDER.
LET'S ORDER THE SHIRT
I'M WEARING RIGHT NOW.
YOU START BY PICKING OUT
YOUR FABRIC.
I LIKE THIS HEAVY PURPLE OXFORD,
WHICH IS A NICE, CASUAL FABRIC.
NEXT,
YOU PICK OUT YOUR COLLAR.
WE'LL GO WITH
A CASUAL BUTTON-DOWN.
NEXT IS YOUR CUFF.
YOU CAN NEVER GO WRONG
WITH A ONE-BUTTON ROUND.
NOW, HERE IS
AN MTailor SPECIALTY --
TUCKED VERSUS UNTUCKED.
YOU WON'T FIND
"TUCKED" AND "UNTUCKED" OPTIONS
AT FUBU SHIRTS IN STORES.
WOW.
HE JUST WENT THERE,
DAYMOND.
OHHH.
NOT A GOOD WAY
TO START A PITCH. GO AHEAD.
BUT NOW WE GET
TO THE REAL SECRET SAUCE,
WHICH IS GETTING MEASURED
BY YOUR PHONE'S CAMERA.
THE MEASUREMENT PROCESS
IS INCREDIBLY EASY,
AND IT TAKES
LESS THAN 30 SECONDS.
AND DAVID HERE WILL SHOW US
HOW EASY IT REALLY IS.
THE FIRST THING YOU DO IS CHANGE
INTO FORM-FITTING CLOTHING,
WHICH DAVID'S ALREADY DONE.
NEXT, YOU FIND A WALL YOU
CAN LEAN YOUR DEVICE AGAINST.
SO,
AS YOU PUT YOUR DEVICE DOWN,
THE LEVEL TELLS YOU
WHICH WAY TO LEAN IT.
ONCE IT TURNS GREEN,
YOU'RE READY TO STAND BACK
AND GET INTO POSITION.
AND THEN YOU DO
A SINGLE SPIN.
AND AFTER HE'S DONE SPINNING,
HE HOPS OFF-SCREEN
SO THE CAMERA CAN TAKE A PICTURE
OF THE BACKGROUND.
AND THEN YOU'RE DONE.
YOU HIT "SUBMIT."
DAVID JUST GOT MEASURED
20% MORE ACCURATELY
THAN A PROFESSIONAL TAILOR
IN UNDER 30 SECONDS.
AND BECAUSE WE CUT OUT
THE TIME-CONSUMING AND EXPENSIVE
IN-PERSON MEASUREMENT PROCESS,
A CUSTOM SHIRT
THAT NORMALLY COSTS $125,
WE CAN SELL FOR $69
FOR A QUALITY, CUSTOM SHIRT.
LET'S SEE HOW DAVID'S SHIRT
CAME OUT.
[ LAUGHS ]
WOW, THAT WAS FAST.
LOOKING GREAT, DAVID.
THANK YOU.
SHARKS,
WE'VE ALREADY LAUNCHED
AND ARE THRIVING
ON BOTH iOS AND ANDROID.
SO, SHARKS,
DO YOURSELF A FAVOR
AND STOP WEARING
ANOTHER MAN'S CLOTHING.
THANK YOU.
[ SIGHS ]
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT...
VERY NICE.
...THIS SHIRT HERE.
BARBARA, STOP WEARING
ANOTHER MAN'S CLOTHING.
OKAY.
HE'S GOT A HUNKY SHAPE ON HIM.
I LIKE HIS ARMS.
DID IT ACTUALLY MEASURE
HIS BICEPS?
Penn: YES.
REALLY?
SO, WE USE OVER 14 MEASUREMENTS
IN EACH SHIRT.
O'Leary:
THE MEASURING TECHNOLOGY,
IS THERE ANYTHING
PROPRIETARY THERE,
OR HAVE YOU JUST TAKEN IT
OFF THE SHELF?
BECAUSE THIS EXISTS
IN OTHER FORMS.
COMPLETELY PROPRIETARY.
DEVELOPED BY ME AND ANOTHER
FRIEND OF MINE FROM STANFORD.
WHAT'S YOUR RETURN RATES?
BECAUSE THAT WOULD TELL ME
WHAT THE INACCURACY IS
IN THE MEASURING.
SURE.
OUR NET,
INCLUDING RE-MAKES,
WHICH IS WHAT
MOST OF OUR RETURNS ARE,
IS ABOUT 15%.
15%?
15% RETURNS?
YES. YOU KNOW, A TYPICAL
ONLINE FASHION STORE
HAS 25% TO 30% RETURN.
John: YOU'RE ASKING
FOR $2.5 MILLION FOR 10%,
SO YOU FEEL THERE SHOULD BE
A $25 MILLION VALUATION
ON THIS COMPANY,
CORRECT?
I'LL DEFINITELY
DISCUSS VALUATION,
IF THAT'S WHAT
YOU WANT TO DISCUSS.
OH, I BET YOU WILL.
OH, NO, WE DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THAT AT ALL TODAY.
BUT WE'LL START
WITH REVENUE.
SO, WE REALLY LAUNCHED
LAST YEAR.
THAT'S WHEN WE STARTED GETTING
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE.
AS OF JULY, WE WERE DOING
150 GRAND A MONTH IN REVENUE.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENED WAS
WE HIT SUPPLY-CHAIN ISSUES,
SO THIS PAST MONTH
WE ACTUALLY DID $130,000.
BUT WE WERE ON TRACK TO DO
$2 MILLION IN REVENUE THIS YEAR.
BUT, UNFORTUNATELY,
WE'LL DO $1.1 MILLION,
'CAUSE WE HAVE TO FIX
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN.
I'M ACTUALLY FLYING TO CHINA
STARTING TOMORROW, DEFINITELY,
TO GET THAT FIXED.
O'Leary:
TALK TO US ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S A BIG HICCUP.
OH, FOR SURE.
THAT'S A 50% MISS.
YES.
BUT WE HAVE -- YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
$1.4 MILLION IN THE BANK,
SO, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
NOT GOING BANKRUPT TOMORROW.
SO, WHAT EXACTLY
WAS THE PROBLEM?
YOU DIDN'T LIKE YOUR PRICING
THAT YOU WERE GETTING?
OUR PRICING,
FRANKLY, WAS --
STARTED,
WE SET UP OUR SUPPLY CHAIN,
WE WERE SELLING
TWO SHIRTS A DAY,
WE'RE PAYING THE SAME PRICE,
EVEN THOUGH WE SELL
THOUSANDS OF SHIRTS A MONTH NOW.
AND WE SPENT A FEW MONTHS
TRYING TO FIX IT.
FRANKLY, YOU KNOW, I'D NEVER
DONE SUPPLY CHAIN BEFORE.
WE HAD MOSTLY FAILED AT IT.
SO, I'M FLYING TO CHINA
AND GONNA BE THERE
INDEFINITELY UNTIL --
WHY ARE YOU PUTTING THIS
AT $25 MILLION VALUATION?
BECAUSE
I CAN SAVE YOU THAT TRIP
IF YOU'LL BRING IT DOWN
TO $5 MILLION.
I COULD SEND YOU
TO TAIWAN AND CHINA
AND GIVE YOU 19 FACTORIES
THAT DO THIS THAT CAN DELIVER.
MAY I ASK YOU,
HOW MUCH DID --
SO, DAYMOND,
FOR YOU SPECIFICALLY,
...I THINK YOU REALLY COULD
BRING INCREDIBLE VALUE
TO HELPING ME
SET UP OUR SUPPLY CHAIN.
SO HE GETS A DISCOUNT?
IF THIS TECHNOLOGY'S THAT GREAT
AND I CAN HELP YOU,
WHY WOULD YOU PUT
A $25 MILLION VALUATION ON IT?
WE'VE ALREADY RAISED MONEY
AT A $10 MILLION VALUATION.
WE THINK WE'VE MADE A LOT
OF PROGRESS SINCE THEN.
OUT OF RESPECT
FOR YOUR OTHER INVESTORS --
I STILL DON'T EVEN THINK
IT'S WORTH $10 MILLION --
WHY'D YOU AT LEAST
START AT $10 MILLION?
ARE WE PLAYING A "YOU GO HIGH,
I GO LOW," THING, OR...?
OH, WE'RE JUST
A VERY DIFFERENT COMPANY
FROM WHEN
WE RAISED $10 MILLION.
YEAH, YOU'RE A COMPANY
THAT MISSED ITS NUMBERS BY 50%.
Sacca:
I GOT TO TELL YOU, I REALLY
RESPECT THE INVESTORS --
WHEN WE RAISED, WE WERE DOING
40 GRAND A MONTH IN REVENUE.
WE'RE GONNA DO 130.
THE TECHNOLOGY WE OFFER
IS COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
FROM ANYTHING
ANYONE HAS REALLY TRIED.
SO, YOU'RE A TECH PLAY.
DEFINITELY YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE
THAT OUR TECHNOLOGY --
BUT WHY DO YOU WANT TO REBUILD
WHAT ALREADY EXISTS?
WHO WANTS
ANOTHER SHIRT COMPANY?
YEAH,
IS THIS A PROOF OF CONCEPT
TO THEN SELL THE SOFTWARE
TO OTHER PEOPLE?
IT'S NOT QUITE THAT.
WE'RE REALLY VERY FOCUSED ON
BUILDING OUR OWN BRAND.
NO ONE BEFORE US HAS
REALLY TRIED TO MAINSTREAM
CUSTOM IN THE SAME WAY.
OR YOU COULD JUST TURN AROUND
AND LICENSE THIS TECHNOLOGY
TO SOME OF THOSE
MULTI-BILLION-DOLLAR COMPANIES
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT.
ARE YOU
A STANFORD ENGINEER?
I WANT TO UNDERSTAND THE VALUE
OF $25 MILLION.
STANFORD,
MATH AND COMPUTER SCIENCE.
YEAH, OKAY.
THE SIZING TECHNOLOGY,
THE CALIBRATION YOU DID,
IS NO SMALL FEAT.
WHAT I THINK IS HARD,
PARTICULARLY FOR
A STANFORD ENGINEER, SOMETIMES,
IS REALIZING THAT TECHNOLOGY,
THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY BE
THE EASIEST PART
OF THIS BUSINESS.
SO, I --
BUT THE REST OF THIS
IS NASTY.
BUILDING A COMPANY FROM SCRATCH,
REMOTELY FROM THE UNITED STATES,
TRYING TO GET
THE STUFF MADE,
TRYING TO SELL IT
TO REAL PEOPLE,
TRYING TO FIT
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF DIFFERENT
BODY COMBINATIONS,
DESPITE YOUR 10,000
COMBINATIONS HERE...
WELL, THAT'S JUST --
THAT'S STYLE.
...IS A HARD BUSINESS.
AND SO FAR, IT'S NOT GOING
THAT GREAT FOR YOU.
RIGHT?
I DISAGREE WITH THAT.
YOU WERE ON TRACK
TO $2 MILLION IN SALES...
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU HAD TO TAKE THE GAP --
YOU HAD
TO LET THE GAS OFF.
THE SHAPE OF YOUR CURVE
IS DOWN AND TO THE RIGHT
INSTEAD OF UP
AND TO THE RIGHT.
AND YOU'VE GOT
GOOD EXPLANATIONS FOR THAT,
BUT IT'S STILL DOWN,
RIGHT?
THAT'S ONLY
IN THE LAST THREE WEEKS.
SO, I WANT TO KNOW,
ARE YOUR EXISTING INVESTORS
WILLING TO INVEST
AT THIS SAME
$25 MILLION PRICE,
OR ARE YOU TRYING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE SHARKS HERE?
♪♪
Narrator:
ALL SHARKS ARE STILL IN,
BUT THEY QUESTION
THE HIGH VALUATION
THAT MILES CAME IN WITH
FOR HIS CUSTOM-SHIRT
TECH COMPANY, MTailor.
ARE YOUR EXISTING INVESTORS
WILLING TO INVEST
AT THE SAME
$25 MILLION PRICE,
OR ARE YOU TRYING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE SHARKS HERE?
♪♪
I'M NOT TRYING
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ANYONE.
I THINK IT'S A FAIR DEAL.
I THINK IF WE WERE
TO GO RAISE A SERIES "A,"
THAT'S -- YOU KNOW, THAT WOULD
BE A VERY FAIR VALUATION.
MY CONCERN IS THAT
THAT'S NOT REFLECTED IN
THE VALUATION, RIGHT?
YOU REALIZE
CHINA ISN'T SET UP YET.
THAT'S PUSHED YOUR CALENDAR OUT
A LITTLE BIT.
YEAH, YOU'RE RIGHT.
AND SO THAT'S NORMALLY
NOT THE PRECURSOR
FOR ASKING FOR A 2.5X
ON YOUR LAST VALUATION.
I DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND.
I THINK JUST GIVEN THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE $1.4 MILLION,
WE THINK WE CAN GET
TO RAMEN PROFITABILITY.
YOU KNOW,
WE'D LIKE TO PUT THE GAS --
WELL, RAMEN PROFITABILITY
IS NOT ATTRACTIVE
TO AN INVESTOR
WHO'S LOOKING FOR
A BIG RETURN
ON THEIR MONEY.
John: WHAT'S
RAMEN PROFITABILITY?
"RAMEN PROFITABILITY" MEANS
THE BUSINESS MAKES ENOUGH MONEY
TO BUY NOODLES
FOR EVERYBODY WORKING THERE.
[ CORCORAN LAUGHS ]
OH,
WHERE I COME FROM,
IT'S CALLED
A WING DINNER PROFITABILITY.
WING DINNER.
YOU HAVE MORE PROTEIN
IN YOUR DEAL.
BUT YOU RIGHT NOW
ARE PRICED TO PERFECTION,
AND I CAN'T
PAY A PERFECT PRICE
FOR A COMPANY
THAT ISN'T PERFECT RIGHT NOW,
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
MILES, IF YOU'D SAY,
"HEY, I MADE A MISTAKE.
I'M DOING THIS.
I'M MOVING TO CHINA,
I DID THIS, DUH-DUH-DUH.
THE PROJECTIONS
WERE WRONG."
YOU'RE EXPLAINING IT AWAY,
BUT WHAT BOTHERS ME --
THERE'S NO SHAME FACTOR
AT ALL.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
PARTY CHATTER ALMOST.
SO, MY STRESS --
I THINK I WOULD
STAY AWAKE AT NIGHT
WORRIED ABOUT WHAT YOUR
NEXT MISTAKE IS GOING TO BE.
OH, I'VE BEEN WORRIED
ABOUT CHINA.
IT'S LIKE, I HAVE --
YOU DON'T LOOK WORRIED
TO ME.
FOR THAT REASON ALONE,
I'M OUT.
AH, YOU KNOW,
CAN'T PLEASE EVERYONE.
WHOA.
WELL,
I DON'T REALLY LIKE YOU...
[ LAUGHS ]
...BUT I LIKE
THE CONCEPT.
YOU CAME IN WITH
A LITTLE BIT OF ATTITUDE.
I LIKE YOU, DAYMOND.
BUT THIS IS
ALL ABOUT BUSINESS.
I'LL GIVE YOU $2.5 MILLION
FOR 17.5%.
I WANT TO LICENSE IT OUT.
I THINK WE HAVE
DIFFERENT STRATEGIC VISIONS.
I'M INTERESTED IN
FOR THE NEAR FUTURE
RAMPING UP
OUR OWN CLOTHING
AND THEN GOING AT
A MUCH HIGHER VALUATION.
SO, THANK YOU, DAYMOND.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT,
BUT I'M GONNA HAVE TO DECLINE.
YOU CAN ALWAYS COME BACK
AND "CUSTOM-TAILOR" THIS
FOR ME IF YOU'D LIKE.
[ Laughing ] OH, GEEZ.
YOU WANT...$22.5 MILLION
POST-VALUATION, $2.5 MILLION?
AND OUR OBJECTIVE IS
TO LICENSE THIS, CORRECT?
SO, THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK
WE REALLY NEED TO DISCUSS.
WE'RE VERY FOCUSED ON
THE NEAR-TERM, NOT IN LICENSING.
I THINK YOU'D REALLY --
IT WOULD POTENTIALLY
DERAIL THE COMPANY.
THAT JUST BECOMES
A REALLY BIG CHALLENGE,
BECAUSE, AT THIS POINT, I HAVE
TO LOOK AT IT LIKE THIS.
I THINK THAT WE CAN BE
GREAT STRATEGIC PARTNERS,
BUT IF I GO AND TAKE MY,
YOU KNOW, $2.5 MILLION
AND TRY TO CONCENTRATE
ON FINDING A SOFTWARE
VERY SIMILAR TO YOURS,
I CAN OWN 100%
OF WHAT I'M CURRENTLY DOING.
AND I THINK
IF YOU WANT TO GO DO THAT,
I THINK, BY ALL MEANS,
GO AHEAD.
I'M OUT.
WHAT IF I SAID TO YOU,
"LOOK, I'M INTERESTED IN YOU,
BUT I DON'T WANT YOU
TO GO TO CHINA"?
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY THINK
YOU'RE GONNA FAIL.
YOU'RE GONNA GO AND TRY
AND REINVENT THE WHEEL
MANUFACTURING SHIRTS,
WHEN REALLY
WHAT YOU SHOULD BE DOING
IS PERFECTING
THIS TECHNOLOGY,
TAKING OUT THAT DELAY
YOU TALKED ABOUT,
WHILE SOMEBODY WITH A REAL BRAND
AND INFRASTRUCTURE
WANTS TO WORK
WITH YOU.
[ CLEARS THROAT ] MYSELF.
I CAN HELP YOU DO THAT.
IF YOU REALLY HAVE
A BETTER MOUSETRAP,
THAT'S INTERESTING TO ME.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $2.5 MILLION IN DEBT,
AND I WANT
2.5% OF THE COMPANY.
I WANT TO MAKE AT LEAST 7%
ON THAT DEBT, OKAY?
AH!
I'LL GIVE YOU 36 MONTHS
TO PAY IT BACK.
IT'S NOT UNREASONABLE.
YEAH, 7% A YEAR?
YEAH.
THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT BAD.
YEAH, IT'S NOT BAD, YEAH.
IT'S NOT A BAD DEAL.
THAT'S THE MOST REASONABLE DEAL
I'VE EVER HEARD FROM YOU.
THAT'S VENTURE DEBT.
YOUR COMPANY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THAT AT THIS POINT.
SUCH A DEAL!
YOU CAN'T TURN THAT DOWN.
MARK,
DO YOU HAVE A COUNTER?
Cuban: SO,
HERE'S MY PROBLEM, RIGHT.
YOU'RE SIMILAR TO ME, BUT
EVEN MORE ARROGANT THAN I WAS,
IF THAT'S POSSIBLE.
[ CORCORAN LAUGHS ]
THAT IS IMPOSSIBLE.
THAT CAN'T HAPPEN.
YEAH, YOU KNOW, WHEN I FIRST
HAD MY FIRST COMPANY
AND I WROTE CODE AND I DID
ALL THE SYSTEMS INTEGRATION.
THE FACT IS THAT YOU'RE THE ONE
THAT HAS TO GO TO CHINA.
THAT IS THE HUGEST MISTAKE
YOU'LL EVER MAKE,
BECAUSE IT SAYS
EITHER YOU'RE AFRAID
OR DON'T KNOW HOW TO HIRE
AND BUILD BENCH STRENGTH.
SO, MY PROBLEM ISN'T
THE VALUATION, RIGHT?
MY PROBLEM IS THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE THE SKILL SET YET
TO BE ABLE TO CREATE
THAT ACCELERATION.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, MARK.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
OKAY, MILES,
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
UNFORTUNATELY, WE'RE
INTERESTED IN EQUITY PARTNERS
THAT ARE GONNA BE FULLY INVESTED
IN THE COMPANY.
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE A BIG
BALLOON PAYMENT OVER OUR HEADS.
WOW.
SO, UNFORTUNATELY,
UNLESS YOU WANT TO GO EQUITY,
WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DECLINE.
WHEN YOU WALK OUT THAT DOOR,
IT'S OVER.
AND YOU'RE GONNA GO HOME TONIGHT
AND CRY LIKE A BABY.
WHEN YOU SAY NO
TO AN OFFER LIKE THAT,
IT ACTUALLY SHOWS ME
YOU DON'T HAVE AS MUCH
CONFIDENCE IN THE BUSINESS
AS I THOUGHT YOU DID.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
SO, I HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE
IN THE BUSINESS.
I DON'T HAVE
AS MUCH CONFIDENCE
IN PAYING BACK $3 MILLION
EXACTLY WHEN HE NEEDS IT.
I CAN'T BELIEVE
YOU'RE NOT TAKING IT.
I'M SHOCKED.
I-I GOT TO SAY NO.
ALL RIGHT, YOU'RE
A DEAD SHIRT WALKING TO ME.
TURN AROUND
AND GET OUT OF HERE.
PLEASE JUST GO AWAY.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU, GUYS.
IT'S BEEN GREAT.
TAKE CARE.
♪♪
I FEEL LIKE I GAVE OUT AN OFFER
THAT I KNEW WE COULD ACCEPT.
UNFORTUNATELY, NONE OF
THE SHARKS TOOK ME UP ON IT,
AND, YOU KNOW, I BENT AS MUCH
AS I THOUGHT WAS REASONABLE
FOR OUR BUSINESS
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN IT SO MUCH
AND I KNOW WHERE WE'RE GOING.